so in recent times I've seen the rise of
top anime list that detailed the anime
that many people would recommend anime
fans to watch but I have yet to see
anything close representing more anime
fans actually end up watching so if you
yourself want to be considered a
well-rounded respect for anime fan fuck
all those other lists telling you what
you need to see this is the actual
top-20 anime every anime fan needs to
watch or like you're probably not a real
anime fan HD number 20
sword art online starting off this list
of course the classic sword art online
which has been on everyone's to watch
this ever since that first aired in the
summer of 2012 now under
absolutely no circumstances should you
actually enjoy sword art online but you
need to watch it to basically shit on
anyone who does
yes the easiest way to make friends and
get popular to talk about how bad
Sword Art Online was even if you didn't
think it was as bad as everyone says
become the life of the party my calling
Kirito and edgy self instead op
douchebag and that the first half was so
much better than a second half and I
guarantee that you will be one of the
cool kids number 19
I ghibli film come on everyone loves
ghibli films even people who hate anime
love ghibli films so you need to love
Ghibli too I mean everyone knows
miyazaki fucking hates anime wanted
like 50 more Hiroshima 'he's so maybe it
doesn't even count as anime just make
sure you watch all the ones you need to
watch
I'm talking spirited away princess
mononoke I literally any other ghibli
field to make it seem like you're not an
uncultured fuck he's only seen spirited
away and Princess Mononoke number 18 a
non ghibli film that is not a Akira or
Ghost in the Shell
that's right general public there are
other anime films that exist you know
there's that film by that guy who made
Digimon films
oh that guy who died too early and that
guy who makes everything look really
pretty
whatever their names is probably
important number 17 an old anime let's
get this straight old anime sucks and
everyone knows it
I mean it's a university proven fact
that anything made before the age of
digital animation looks God ugly and
isn't worth your time have the further
back you go the worse it gets
but you're always against that
one fan who's about your dad's age
reminiscing about that time he watched
Macross or some nineties ova literally
no one has ever heard of his 50th
generation but first recording whatever
that is
so you always need to be able to say
something like yeah
astro-boy was my favorite anime growing
up too
I'm he'll probably leave you alone
number sixteen Shirobako this one is
more for the critics or the ones who
want to be more knowledgeable about the
industry as a whole
I mean you could do your own research on
the inner workings of the anime industry
to be well-informed and everything but
fuck all that
just watch your Shirobako and you're now
have a PhD in anime production so your
opinion will now be infinitely more
well-informed and anyone else who hasn't
seen it bonus points if you're so read
Bakuman and have become an expert in
manga artist too. Number 15 the nostalgic
shows you watched as a kid
ah yes were you a nineties kid who grew
up and pokemon a dragon ball z does
old-school Toonami bring nothing but
Joys memories to you maybe came a bit
later when Naruto, Bleach, and One
Piece we're getting popular, either way
these are the shows that we'll always be
close to you no matter what anyone else
says, help you don't even know if they
were as great as you remember it but
that's ok you were a dumb naive kid back
then and you had shit taste but at least
you can reflect it now that you're older
and wiser with an equally shit tastes
number 14 a hentai yes real fucking
tired of the rest of the world think
that every anime you watch is sometimes
called raping freak show and that every
time your mom walks in the room is
guaranteed to get out one thing without
girl trips over exposing her massive
tits you can spend your entire life time
explaining that an amazing wide and
varied medium containing some of the
most compelling series of all time but
also provides a unique platform for
storytelling real talk here guys
everyone's watch him to at least one
here even the girls just remember the
most important rule of all we're never
allowed to discuss it or ever admit that
we have in public no one must ever know
Number 13 Legend of the Galactic Heroes
now this one is actually a trick one
because no one actually needs to watch
Legend of the Galactic Heroes they just
need to say they want to watch it
see once you watch the Legend of the
Galactic Heroes there is no going back
as an anime fan as every anime you
watch from then on will be utter trash
compared to it and you will quite
literally stand
above everyone who has not seen Legend
of the Galactic Heroes, so if you're not
yet prepared to send to the next plane
yet just say yeah like i'll definitely
watch it one day. Number 12 an anime
where you argue over best girl you're
not a true anime fan unless you've
argued over which girl in a particular
series is indeed best girl, forget
politics forget religion you have not
seen for conflict until you see a group
of nerds argue over which fictional 2d
character has the most hypothetically
appealing trace in a made-up cast of
anime blood is shed friendships are
lost and this is the place where you
find your true brothers in arms but the
one irrefutable fact that you must take
by is that anyone who does not agree
review has shit taste
conversely once you get bored of
fighting the neverending best girl wars
come watch you know show to see that a
perfectly peaceful utopian society can't
exist in the real world. Number 11
something with boobies, because boobies
Number 10
that's one hot anime that everyone is
watching every season
you know the one I mean that one that
everyone is exclusively talking about
because apparently no one is watching
anything else this season
it doesn't matter if you are you won't
find anyone else to talk about it with
anyway so you might as well get on the
hype train and see what all the fuss is
about
just be prepared for the shit storm that
comes after it ends you've got to either
love it or think is an absolute piece of
overhyped shit cause any other opinion
doesn't count the total worry it'll all
blow over in about two weeks anyway
because there was already moved on to
new season then all we have to do is
pick the next hot anime coming out and
repeat the cycle once again forever but
before you do that you need to watch
number 10.5 the 50 anime your pickup at
the start of every season 2 then drop
after three episodes come on it's the
start of the season everything looks
good everything has potential I mean
you're watching shows you would normally
watch but it could be good right so you
gotta get an impression then after two
or three episodes you realize what a
stupid idiot you've been trying to keep
up with 50 episodes every week and just
continue to watch the same old shit you
always end up watching you on original
play. Number 9 Avatar the Last Airbender
one of the greatest animates ever exist
that everyone remembers growing up with
on TV
what this isn't actually an anime that
can't be right i mean it looks like an
anime feels like an anime and sounds
like an anime so who cares where is made
right, i mean God forbid we classify this
as *cough* cartoon does this look like fucking
family guy to you
yeah? No. Number 8 Boku no Pico and Cory
in the House I'd be remiss if i didn't
include the university agreed
masterpieces that are Boku no Pico and
Cory in the House these two classics
have weaved the way to anime culture
revolutionising the way we see modern
anime cementing themselves as the I'm
just fucking kidding guys I'm putting
this here to a piece of people laughing
overused jokes hashtag here come that
boy harambee. Number 7
Gundam if you're Indiana me found for
any extended period of time you will
inevitably run into the gundam fan so
it's important that you can hold a
respectful conversation with them, but
actually becoming a proper gundam fan
and watching all the Gundams will take
you about 50 billion 3927 hours three
settings of the Lord of the Rings
trilogy and a game of dota 2 so what you
really need to do is watch a gundam show
any Gundam show doesn't matter which one I
mean they're all basically the same show
anyway you got giant robots, politics
giant robot the important thing is you
now have a favorite gundam, so when a
gundam fan asks you which one your
favorite one is you can always answer
the correct answer of the best one they
don't know exactly which one you mean
right?
Gundam fans and if they do ask which is
your favorite gundam timeline simply
answer yes!
Number 6 cowboy bebop ever since it
first aired on adult swim this show has
become an instant classic for Western
anime fans but is it a must watch
because of its memorable characters
excellent soundtrack or is definitively
cool style fuck No! It's a must watch so
that next time you meet a sub elitists
who claims all dubs a shit it's the one
show you can rub right now
ugly face that's universally irrefutable
Number 5 attack on full metal death note
punch man that's right is the definitive
best-selling anime series of everyone's
fucking scene and likes including you!
just remember you always have to have
one of these in your top 10 favorite
anime but you are absolutely not
allowed to have them
as your number one cause everyone else
likes them so you'll just be seen as an
unoriginal cunts. Number 4 episode 3 of
madoka magica I don't know I guess
something big is supposed to happen this
episode I mean everyone keeps talking
about to this day I don't I'm fuckin our
Number 3 a high school anime look it's
not a proper anime unless it's set in
high school if it's not then you know
the characters are high school age by
becoming an anime fan you basically
attend the Japanese High School yourself
I mean you'll be an expert in attending
opening ceremonies organizing school
festivals and sitting in the backseat of
a classroom by the window
don't forget this also means that you've
seen a lot of slice-of-life animate, see
slice of life is a completely unique
genre that only exists in anime which
means no one actually knows what the
fuck you properly means so if it's set
in high school
it probably has some slice-of-life
elements in it and everyone fucking
loves that. Number 2 Neon Genesis
Evangelion definitely one of the most
influential animate ever come out every
fan knows that one day they must
eventually watch Neon Genesis Evangelion
in order to have an opinion on Neon
Genesis Evangelion whether you love it
hate it don't skip the ending or
understand every intricate detail can
write a 50 page thesis deconstructing it
even if all you really care about is his
best girl between masquerade it is
imperative that you have an opinion on
it because it will be the topic of
discussion for approximately the next
seven trillion years. Number 1 your
favorite anime that didn't make this
list
look guys I know that this is the actual
top-20 anime that every fan needs to
watch and the fact that your personal
favorite anime didn't make this list is
an absolute travesty
it doesn't matter that I might not have
seen the anime yet oh I don't think it's
as great as you too and that it's
impossible to list that matches
everyone's taste your anime should have
been here and I obviously don't know
what I'm talking about
so please be sure to leave a million
comments tell me about that one anime
missed and leave a dislike so I've
recognize the greatness of that anime
that i missed which I definitely will
after you do you know what you should do
that even if your favorite anime was on
this list but not at number one and that
was it
hope you've now learned something about
yourself as an anime
and because as part of the title of this
video if you haven't seen absolutely
everything on this list then obviously
you're not real anime fan yeah well just
like watch whatever you want to watch
your fucking mother
hey guys apologies my camera still being
fixed they don't get see my lovely face
just yet
thank you very much this month to Gabe
Brown, Thomas B, Vincent Mooney,
Merederai, and everyone on Patreon for
helping making these videos possible i'm
also having a special double giveaway
this month for my patron so go check it
out if you want those your underwear
more sustain my asian house for a few
months so hello from Thailand I don't
get to see many white people here anyway
that's it for me though check out my
other stuff is this your first time here
but apart from thats i've been giving up
and i'll see you all next time